A lot of people don't
realize that we're
about more than just Android
development here at Google.
For starters, we're a big iOS
developer ourselves, right?
We've got the Google Search
App, and Inbox, and YouTube,
and Maps, and a whole lot more.
I mean, come to think
of it, we probably
have just as many
libraries available
for outside developers to use.
But it's funny.
When a lot of folks
think about where
to go to look for
solutions to help them
with their iOS development,
they don't come to Google.
It just doesn't
appear on their mind.
I guess that's something
I'm looking to change.
And to be fair,
we haven't always
made that information
easy to find.
I mean, the first time I
did a series of screencasts
on how to add Google
services to your iOS app,
I ended up publishing it in
the Android Developers channel.
And the comments
were pretty much what
you might expect-- fanboys.
But that made me realize
that we really needed a place
to put some of these developer
videos for iOS folks,
and that's kind of how
Route 85 came about.
So where'd the name come from?
Well, you're going to have to
figure that out for yourself.
You might want to
try Googling it.
Hm.
Some of our shows, they're
fairly Google specific,
but a lot of our
stuff just is kind
of general purpose information.
So even if you're not at all
interested in learning anything
about Google on iOS,
you should still
watch because you just
might learn something.
So come join us, right
here on Route 85.
One tip is to use Bezier paths
to define your shadow's shape.
Let's review that giant
URL one more time, here.
Woah!
[CRASH]